we're learning new details about what
saudi arabia's government calls its
crackdown on corruption
we recently visited saudi arabia for
this sunday's 60 minutes and got a rare
interview
with the powerful crown prince mohammed
bin salman
last november he led the crackdown that
detained saudi princes businessmen
and former government officials at the
ritz-carlton hotel
in the capital riyadh one of his top
advisors is muhammad al-shaikh
and he was closely involved in what
happened at the ritz
what happened at the ritz
anti-corruption crackdown was
was very simple we we had a serious
problem with corruption
the crown prince actually spoke about it
a couple of times
publicly and said we have a real problem
and given the structure of some of these
corruption cases we were worried that if
we started processing people
one at a time that some of the money
might be siphoned out of the kingdom
that it would have a severe negative
impact on the country and the economy
we had to do what we did at the ritz
for foreigners who live in a democracy
where there are charges filed there's
due process
there's a trial could they look at this
and say
i'll take my money elsewhere but even in
democracies where there is due process
there is
trial there's also settlement procedures
and a lot of people do go through these
settlement procedures
were you surprised it took as long as it
did because the ritz was closed for a
while
given the magnitude and and the size
of what happened i actually think it was
an accomplishment that it happened so
quickly
and that it was dealt with in in what i
believe a very efficient manner
well we'll have more of what exactly
happened in our full report with the
crown prince sunday night on 60 minutes
it airs at 7
6 central right here on cbs